well I got a question recently about a
couple who started practicing Islam a
little bit later in their lives and they
tried to adjust their lifestyle
according to the principles of Islam and
it takes some change it takes some time
and one of the difficulties within that
relationship within that family was that
the wife had trouble wearing hijab we're
observing the modest Islamic dress and
the head covering and all the other
things that are associated with the
principle of hijab and how women should
be dressing so the husband initially was
thinking you know what I'll wait a
little while and hopefully you know try
to encourage her she maybe she just
needs some time there's a lot of family
members around none of them are
practicing like this none of them
they're gonna look at her funny they're
gonna make fun of her so he kind of you
know played it down for a while
and the sister herself would say I just
don't feel like I'm ready yet but time
passed
months passed years passed and now it's
been 10 years and the sister is still
not changing her dress she's not changed
this aspect of her lifestyle and the
husband is basically just giving up the
idea and say you know what there's
really nothing I can do I don't want to
cause more problems within the family so
let me just leave it you know I'm not
gonna not gonna push this and it's okay
you know I guess I'm just gotten used to
this fact that she dresses like this and
really not much I can do about it you
know I have to two pieces of advice you
know one for the sister you know the
wife who's actually going through this
and then a piece of advice for the
husband for the wife I would say that
you know he started practicing
practicing Islam and one of the things
that we have to keep in mind is that
when we start practicing Islam there's
gonna be help from Allah but there's
also going to be some challenges that we
encounter and remember Allah is always
there to help you as long as you're
putting in your effort you're putting in
your best effort unless got your back
and when you're making that transition
when you're making that life change into
Islam you should take it slowly you
take a little bit of time to make sure
you're adapting and you're adjusting but
you shouldn't take too long you should
make sure that whatever you're doing
you're doing it to please your Creator
you're doing it to please your Lord to
please Allah and we're not here on this
earth to please human beings so it's
very important to understand that there
is something that Allah wants from us
and when you want something from us and
it's everything he asks us to do is very
reasonable we got to look back deep down
inside our heart and saying what's
stopping me from fulfilling the
commandment that Allah has given me you
got to look into it and you say well I
don't not ready yet I need some more
time and when what will it take to get
ready will it take a few months will it
take some sign from Allah will it take
all the people around you in your family
to stop criticizing you to never give
you a funny glance or something like
that those things are never gonna happen
that's just the reality they're not
gonna happen the prophets were made fun
of the Companions were made fun of and
Muslims today there's gonna be there's
gonna be naysayers they're gonna talk
and they're gonna do these things so
once we understand this is what Allah
wants we got to make sure number one
understand that despite what we feel
despite some of the difficulties we do
it for for the cause of Allah and number
two realize that there's a wisdom behind
this and that modesty is actually the
best way in the best way to live life
this is the best thing for society
actually so when we see the wisdom
behind the command and we understand
that it is a command we shouldn't wait
too long and we should adjust ourselves
for the husband I would say there is an
aspect of trying to be soft trying to
just hold back and say I don't want to
push it I don't want to force it people
are already looking at me as being kind
of you know too tough and they're not
religious they're not practicing and
they look at me as being some kind of
extreme radical or whatever it is just
because I pray five times a day you know
what don't worry about all those things
don't worry about the naysayers and also
understand that you have a
responsibility because you are a husband
you have a responsibility over the
family the Prophet peace be upon him
said that all of you are like shepherds
and your
sponsible over your flock of sheep so in
that sense we're all we all have some
level of responsibility and a man has a
responsibility over his family just
think about it brother you know you got
if your wife goes out and she's dressing
in skin tight clothing and she likes to
wear makeup and people like that
attention but you know what that
attention is not always healthy
especially not healthy for your marriage
when you're gonna have other guys
staring at her fantasizing about her you
don't know what they might have in their
mind when they go back in the room what
they're thinking what they're doing and
they got your wife in their mind think
about that so you should have this the
sense of you know protection for your
wife you should have this love and this
care and this concern I don't want other
people disrespecting my wife by looking
at her and making her some type of sex
object or just looking at her body or
something like that so we have a
responsibility in Islam and you should
step up and fulfill that responsibility
with wisdom with gentle admonition but
also it's important you realize that
your role is not to just sit back and
wait when it comes to your wife when it
comes to your kids and say hopefully
I'll just make du'a maybe they'll change
no there's a greater responsibility and
when everyone fulfills their own
responsibility not only their families
are in check everyone in society will
fulfill their responsibilities that
society will be a better society so I
would say with wisdom
make sure you fulfill that
responsibility and really try to
motivate and encourage her and make sure
that at least if she's not gonna cover
her hair at least the clothing becomes
more and more modest over time so it
gets at least closer to what the Islamic
guidelines are when it comes to clothing